[موسيقى]
ادي العناوين المشاهدين لكننا نبدا من
الاخبار العاجله في غزه حيث افادت مصادر
في المقاومه الفلسطينيه للجزيره باغتيال
قائد بارز في سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي بجانبه قال المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان طائرات
اسرائيليه نفذت غارات على اهداف تابعه
لحركه الجهاد في قطاع غزه وقالت مره اسئله
الجزيره ان الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
طلبت من سكان مستوطنات غلا في غزه الدخول
الى الملاجئ فورا اضافت مراسله الجزيره
انه تم نقله عده اصابات جراء غارات على
هدف بحي الشجاعيه شرق مدينه غزه من جانبها
افادت مصادر فلسطينيه طبيه باصابه عدد من
الفلسطينيين جراء غارتين على شقق سكنيه
بغزه ورفح وقالت القناه الثالثه عشر
الاسرائيليه انها تتوقع عده ايام من
المواجهه المسلحه مع التنظيمات
الفلسطينيه في غزه